[Musik]
strahlende aussichten für die cdu top
umfragewerte bei den kommunalwahlen in
sachsen und thüringen platz eins doch
ukraine krieg und inflation könnten
daran mehr anteil haben als das
wahlprogramm unter den bedingungen der
krise wählen die deutschen viel mutiger
als sonst und zukunftsangst und beim
angst management tendiert man eher auf
das etablierte auf das bekannte und
nicht zu den extremen seit der
gewonnenen nrw-wahl jubelt die union
zieht sich zurück an der spitze doch hat
friedrich merz seit seiner wahl zum
vorsitzenden wirklich das ruder
herumgerissen punktuell situativ ja
langfristig keineswegs denn sie ist nach
wie vor als cdu eine wahrgenommene
männer partei und auch kompetenzfelder
sind und ich ausreichend abgedeckt die
cdu auf selbstfindungstrip der
generalsekretär will eine frauenquote
und der vorsitzende hat sich da
inzwischen zurück wohl auch weil er weiß
wie viel sprengstoff in dem thema steckt
und bei mir im studio begrüße ich jetzt
den cdu generalsekretär mario czaja
guten morgen herzlich willkommen guten
morgen als sie selbst wollen ja die
frauenquote was es denn eigentlich mit
ihrem chef den cdu vorsitzenden
friedrich merz was hören sie von ihnen
wird er sich morgen dafür oder dagegen
aussprechen friedrich merz ist genauso
wie ich dafür dass wir eine neue
willkommenskultur eine bessere einladung
auch gerade für frauen in der cdu
aussprechen nur jedes vierte mitglied in
der cdu ist eine frau damit können wir
nicht zufrieden sein wir wollen mehr
frauen auch in mandaten haben und er hat
immer gesagt die frauenquote ist die
zweitbeste lösung aber uns hat noch
keiner eine bessere genannt und die
strukturen satzungskommission hat einen
vorschlag unterbreitet wie wir den
anteil bei frauen in den mann dazu bei
den mandatsträgern bei unseren
funktionen während innerhalb der partei
über das erhöhen und diesen vorschlag
der strukturen satzungskommission werden
wir im september auf dem parteitag
beraten und jetzt habe ich mir noch
nicht ganz raus gehört vielleicht wissen
sie es auch von friedrich merz nicht
oder sie wollen es nicht sagen wie er
tatsächlich zu der quote steht wird er
oder erwarten sie von ihrem parteichef
nicht auch dass er ganz klar stellung
bezieht weil das was der parteichef sagt
wird ja ganz maßgeblich auch die
stimmung innerhalb der partei
beeinflussen und werden sie für die
quote sind würden sie sich doch
vielleicht dasselbe von 3 märz menschen
also friedrich merz hat gesagt wir
führen die diskussion in der partei und
er hat auch einen klaren kurs in der
frage er möchte nämlich auch eine
bessere einladungs kultur für frauen
innerhalb der cdu aussprechen er hat
immer gesagt für ihn ist das nicht die
beste aller lösungen aber er sieht
bislang keine andere er ist auch dafür
dass wir die vorschläge der strukturen
satzungskommission die lange erarbeitet
sind dass wir diese vorschläge auf dem
parteitag unterstützen und begleiten und
dass wir diesen weg gemeinsam gehen aber
dabei eben auch zusammenbleiben es gibt
eben auch argumente die dagegen sprechen
aber das ist eine große einladungs
kultur dafür aussprechen wollen und
deswegen bin ich auch ein großer
befürworter dass wir diesen weg gehen
und wenn es keine alternative gibt dann
wird friedrich merz auch irgendwann habe
ich dazu noch farbe bekennen müssen und
sie haben selbst gesagt nur jedes vierte
mitglied etwa ist weiblich wir wissen
auch die cdu stellt keine
ministerpräsidentin kein
cdu-landesverband wird von einer frau
geführt woran liegt das eigentlich
die situation ist so dass innerhalb der
cdu in der vergangenheit aufgrund auch
der sehr gefestigten strukturen männer
mehr verantwortung übernommen haben das
ist aber auch schwer fällt von der
kommunalen ebene bis hin zur landesebene
frauen für die politischen ämter
ebenfalls bei uns zu begeistern und das
sind noch unterschiedlich rahmen uns die
frage gibt es verbindliche anfangs und
endzeiten von sitzungen können wir
stärker auch auf die hybrid pflicht
gehen von meetings dass wir das die
vereinbarkeit von familie und beruf von
familie und pflege möglich ist und das
sind mehrere bestandteile die wir in der
strukturen satzungskommission besprochen
haben um diese einladung skulptur
auszusprechen weil es gibt nicht den
einen lösungsweg sondern sicherlich mehr
dann möchte ich mit ihnen nach
über das thema inflation sprechen die
cdu hat sich beim tank rabatt im
bundestag enthalten zurückgehalten
genauso wie beim mindestlohn warum ist
die cdu fraktion nicht klarer also beim
mindestlohn haben wir deutlich zum
ausdruck gebracht wir sind für 12 euro
mindestlohn das haben wir in köln auf
der gemeinsamen präsidiumssitzung von
cdu und csu beschlossen wir sind aber
der auffassung dass dieser mindestlohn
in zukunft auch wieder von den
tarifpartnern von gewerkschaften und
arbeitgebern war verhandelt werden muss
und kein politischer mindestlohn wird
deswegen haben wir im deutschen
bundestag wo es ja eine mehrheit für den
mindestlohn gehabt gesagt unsere
position dazu ist sehr klar die zwölf
euro sind der richtige schritt derzeitig
das system muss aber wieder politik fern
gestaltet werden man bei der frage der
inflation und beim tank rabatt haben wir
gesagt es gibt viel einfachere
möglichkeiten runter mit der energie
steuern runter mit der mehrwertsteuer
macht jeweils 20 cent rabatt auf den
spritpreis 40 cent in summe und dass die
fdp ein solch
bürokratisches monster schafft was
sichtlich nicht wirkt was wir auch
vorher gesehen haben dass das passiert
das ist hätten wir uns so nicht
vorstellen können unserer weg war ein
einfacher nämlich einfache steuersenkung
und das hätte auch frühzeitiger
entlastet als das derzeitig der fall ist
dann können sie vielleicht die
cdu-position noch in sachen kartellamt
einmal klar ziehen sollte das kartellamt
intervenieren sie wissen da gibt es auch
eine große diskussion und auch die über
gewinn steuer also robert habeck hat im
märz gesagt er ruft das kartellamt an
und er wird mit dem kartellamt über
diese fragen sprechen er hat das bisher
nicht getan wir erwarten dass er die
dinge die er dazu angekündigt hat auch
umsetzt robert habeck hat unsere
unterstützung dass er beim kartellamt
die notwendigen schritte einleitet es
ist ja ersichtlich dass
höchstwahrscheinlich fragen der
preisabsprachen hier auch grundlage der
derzeitigen preispolitik sind und
deswegen er muss ist einfach nur tun und
bei der über gewinn steuer es ist
richtig dass man auch darauf achtet dass
jetzt nicht gewinner dieser dieses
krieges sich auf kosten insbesondere
derjenigen die ein kleines einkommen
haben bereichern aber die über gewinn
steuer gab es schon mal eine diskussion
in deutschland
während der pandemie und es gibt ein
gutachten des wissenschaftlichen
parlamentsdienst dass das nicht geht
also das sind sehr populistische
forderungen die wir da immer wieder
hören wenn der weg dafür möglich ist
muss die regierung den vorschlag
unterbreiten die wahrheit ist aber sie
haben sich für ein demokratisches system
entschieden und jetzt greifen die
instrumente dieses bürokratischen
systems nicht sie hätten auf unsere
vorschläge eingehen können dann wären
wir heute ganz viele schritte weiter
sagt der cdu generalsekretär mario czaja
bei uns im interview vielen dank dafür